ending tonight on a poignant note the
end of an era
it was just three weeks ago that the
struggling and fledgling state of Chas
seceded from downtown Seattle from the
u.s. itself a week later after internal
revolution it became chop but the new
name didn't stop the turmoil within
after a series of killings the world's
youngest country also had the world's
highest per capita murder rate sensing
weaknesses enemies pounced Seattle mayor
Jenny Durkin who praised chop just weeks
ago sent in police to reenact the
country back to the US and now comes the
difficult task of reintegrating its
citizens into American life Jason Rance
has been tracking Chaz for us and
chopped in the very beginning he joins
us tonight this is a kind of a powerful
moment to see the fledgling nation
disappear it is and you know I hate to
break it to you we were not greeted as
liberators today and it is kind of
bizarre to figure out what we're gonna
do with these folks from chop because
you know it is it are they refugees I
mean we kicked them out of their
sovereign land with overwhelming force
via bicycle cops and they did put up a
little bit of a fight with their
fortified borders of old couches which
by the way not what they used to be
because those bike cops got through them
very very quickly they must have been
IKEA so we're gonna try to figure out
what exactly do we do with these folks I
mean we're talking about a whole bunch
of 20-something imbecilic progressive
white privilege do you think that they
basically don't have to work for a
living they can just turn to socialism
and everything will be handed to them do
we really even want them in Seattle I
think we should give them to Portland
you know hunger really helps reeducate
people no one ever does that in our
country by the way I'm just I'm glad to
see us win a war definitively for the
first time in a long time good for us
this was war we could win where are
these refugees going to go are they
going to continue to stew in their own
filth on the streets of Seattle are they
going to move to Portland well they're
kind of looking for another home there's
some rumors that they're going to try to
take up some new space outside of the
West Precinct so they're going from the
East police precinct to the West police
precinct we don't know exactly who's
going to be the
leadership this time obviously like a
phoenix rising through the flames of a
dumpster fire a Samoan came up to be a
really big leader and then he's kind of
disappeared so we don't know who's going
to take the mantle and leave these these
lost souls to their next homeland so do
you think what are the chances Raz
Simone
goes back to his real job which was
renting his apartment on Airbnb his
Apartments on Airbnb way way way better
than living out on a tent in front of a
police station yes next to a parks oh I
mean he maybe should go back to that and
maybe pursue his rap career I mean I'm
very curious cuz he's living on the
streets now he's a chopped leader I want
to see those lyrics I want to hear the
the soul come out his story he's got a
story to tell
and I'm here to listen he's the first
world leader to emerge from the gig
economy and so you know history books on
their point Jason great to see you
tonight thank you for your tireless
William Chazz